[Musique]
pour
chaque fois tu arrives dans un endroit
où de 10 militants des bénévoles qui
donnent des heures pour une idée pour
une cause puis qu'ils disent ok c'est
toi qui est le porteur de ça et l'on
s'exprime de l'affection ces gens-là et
expriment de l'engagement c'est toujours
extrêmement émouvant le politicien est
aussi émus de croiser beaucoup de jeunes
au sein des troupes bloquistes poing des
faux agent un gars ici indéniable du
renouvellement de son parti florent
sabourin qui n'a que 15 ans a passé son
congé lundi et beaucoup de week end
depuis six mois a aidé le bloc québécois
le fait que le parti était qualifié de
moribonds n'avait pas refroidi ses
ardeurs
non parce que moi je m'engage pour ce
que je crois je m'engage pas pour ce que
les gens disent dans les médias ça
m'importe peu
on a fait le plus possible mais ses
locaux après les encouragements à son
équipe
le chef reprend la route pour une
dernière tournée dans la circonscription
de belles chambly qu'il apprend à
connaître ministre bout comme ça yves
françois blanchet dit que le contact
intense avec les électeurs ces derniers
mois plan un peu transformé l'ancien
ministre de l'environnement de pauline
marois avait la réputation d'être sans
pitié avec ses adversaires
adam la mer des gens merci beaucoup
monsieur la modestie n'était pas ma
première marque de commerce
parce qu'il y avait un ton un peu plus
cinglant mais lorsqu'on avait connu dans
mon passé politique
et ça s'est rapidement installé d'être à
l'écouté plus on est à l'école de plus
on est sobre dans le propos lui la
réponse des gens au plus les gens si
reconnaissons le premier débat en
français a été un tournant pour le chef
bloquiste
les québécois ont découvert un homme
intelligent particulier autant pause il
n'y a pas de bandits qui travaille chez
snc lavalin parce qu'il ya eu une
maladresse grave de monsieur trudeau je
lui avais conseillé de ne pas être
cinglant de garder son calme de bien
passer ses idées de parler quand même
avec un débit intéressant que les gens
puisse la comprendre qu'ils apprennent à
connaître ses idées plus que l'image de
bataillon des bourdes excuses il faut
que je prenne ça les gilles durant la
pause repas le politicien reçoit l'appel
de son prédécesseur gilles duceppe veut
savoir si son fils a vraiment des
chances de l'emporter dans lac saint
jean a collé dernier se sent bon moi je
suis très confiant alexis mais nous
avons aussi je t'aime beaucoup
le bloc québécois a fait plusieurs gains
dans les régions
j'ai eu mes appartenant
la circonscription bon port côte de
beaupré île d'orléans charlevoix est
remporté par caroline desbiens la
candidate qui avait dit craindre que sa
fille doivent porter un voile pour aller
à l'épicerie
si les électeurs d'une circonscription
choisi quelqu'un pour les représenter
après les incidents ça dispose
entièrement de cet enjeu
[Applaudissements]
le chef de parti prépare rarement ses
discours cette fois ci il a écrit le
texte pour ne pas être trop ému
permettez moi de remercier nancy et les
enfants pour leur patience et beaucoup
mieux pour leurs encouragements
j'ai toujours énormément de misère à
faire un discours qualifié là parce que
ça d'équité bonjour dans un discours
j'ai comme toujours une boule à la gorge
le chef du bloc québécois a l'impression
d'être poussée par un nouveau vent
nationaliste qu'il a contribué à
insuffler pour quelqu'un qui connaissait
les noms des menaces de rené lévesque à
11 ans avec ton visage dessus aussi être
parti de si loin que j'ai eu la chance
de vivre des dernières semaines où cette
tribune vie absolument extraordinaire
une sorte
[Applaudissements]